-Welcome back, everybody.
Now, I love dogs,
and I really love talented dogs.
And we found some talented dogs
that we think
you're gonna love.
It's time for "What's Up, Dog?"
♪ What's up, dog,
what's up, dog? ♪
♪ What's up, dog? ♪
-This is "What's Up, Dog?",
the "Tonight Show" showcase
for talented dogs.
Now, let's say what's up
to our first dog.
Welcome.
Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello.
How you doing?
Nice to see you.
Hey, bud, nice to see you.
How are you?
Hello --
Oh, hi.
How you doing?
Nice to see you.
What are your guys' names first?
-I'm Hailey.
-I'm Nick.
-All right, Hailey, Nick.
And what is your dog's name?
-This is Darrell the dog.
-Hi, Darrell the dog.
Hi --
Hi, Darrell.
Nice to -- oh, I see
you're wearing a bow tie.
That's very nice.
Now, what is Darrell's talent?
-He loves sports.
But right now,
his very favorite is hockey.
-He loves hockey.
Okay, interesting.
So, wait.
He plays hockey?
-He plays hockey.
-Oh, my gosh.
All right,
this is gonna be fanta--
Oh, wow, here we go.
All right.
So there's a goal there.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-There's a --
-Goalie.
-That's a goalie.
I thought it was a sloth.
Okay, thank you.
-Also that, also that.
-So, Darrell --
so, what do we have to do
for this?
-So, I have my handyman
over here.
-Okay, yep.
-He's gonna help me
put the ball down.
And first, he's gonna
get himself ready and pumped-up.
Darrell.
-Oh, watch out.
He's wandering off.
He's an attack dog, everybody.
Darrell, come here.
Darrell?
-Okay.
-Come on, Darrell.
-Now we're gonna
give him the stick.
Are you ready, bud?
Yes!
Oh, you're ready.
He's ready.
And we're gonna
give him the stick.
And he's gonna go play hockey.
Ready, bud?
-Oh, Darrell, good job.
-Yes.
Let's play hockey, okay?
[ Laughter ]
All right, yes.
We're ready.
All right, let's go.
-Go for it, Darrell.
-Go hockey!
Hockey, bud.
[ Laughter ]
-You're close.
He's getting it.
-All right,
third try's the charm.
-No, he got it, he got it.
Come on, Darrell.
Maybe don't use the stick.
-Go, go, go.
[ Laughter ]
-You sure the dog does this?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
And -- ready?
-Yeah.
-Hockey, bud.
Ready?
Hit the ball, hit the ball.
-Yeah, start there.
-Let's start right there.
-Start right --
And hockey.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Darrell!
Darrell, come here!
Wow!
High five, high five.
Oh, thank you.
Wow.
He shoots, he scores.
Darrell, good job.
Don't be scared, Darrell.
You're okay.
You want to
get the leash on Darrell?
-Good boy!
-Thank you guys very much.
Great job, Darrell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Build the suspense.
Well done.
For a second there, I'm not sure
that was Darrell's talent.
But, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He gave me a high five
very quickly.
Let's meet our next dog.
Here we go.
Wow, wow, ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello. Jimmy.
-Hello.
-Nice to see you.
What's your name?
-My name is Kelly.
-Hey, Kelly.
And what's the dog's name?
-This is Zain.
-Hi, Zain.
Hi, Zain. Hi.
Oh, yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
Now, Zain is very cute.
What does Zain do?
-Zain is going to achieve
every dog's dream.
He's going to chase his tail
and catch it.
[ Laughter ]
-Chase his tail and catches it.
-And catch his own tail.
-No, Zain --
-Can you sit?
-What's happening?
-Can you wave hello?
Wave hello.
[ Audience "Awws" and applause ]
Good boy.
Say hello.
Good.
-That's very cute.
I'll let you take it from here.
-Down.
Zain, are you shy?
Are you shy?
[ Audience "Awws" and applause ]
-What?
-It's okay.
You don't have to be shy.
Can you get your tail?
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
That's what I'm talking about
right there!
Zain, well done!
-Good job.
-Thank you very much
for being here.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Good job, Zain.
That was great.
Thank you very much.
Not too shabby.
-Let's go. Come on.
Now it's time
to meet our last dog.
Come on over here.
Hello.
Nice to see you.
Jimmy. Nice to see you.
What is your name?
-My name's Glen Wolfe.
-Hey, Glen.
What is your dog's name?
-Buddy Mercury.
[ Laughter ]
-Buddy Mercury is here.
Oh, my God.
Hey, Buddy.
Nice to see you.
How are you?
Oh, wow.
Hi, Buddy.
Nice to see you.
How old is Buddy?
-He's about 8.
-8 years old.
Okay.
And when did you realize
Buddy had this talent?
-About five or six years ago.
-Yeah.
So, it's a good bit.
Five or six years ago.
I'm assuming
the dog plays the piano.
-Yeah, he plays the piano
and sings at the same time.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-It's a double --
I gotta see this.
Now we're talking.
This is it.
Whenever you're ready,
I'd like to see it.
Thank you, Glen.
-Yes.
[ Notes play ]
♪♪
-All right, good boy.
-Very short song.
[ Notes play ]
♪♪
[ Dog howls ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good dog!
Good dog!
That's a great job!
[ Laughs ]
That was fantastic, Buddy!
Hey, come on over here,
everybody.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Guys, if you have a dog with a
fun talent, I want to see it.
Submit a video of your dog
to whatsupdog@tonightshow.com.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Savannah Guthrie
and Hoda Kotb.
Come on back.